مافيش حاجه شكلها عامل كده احنا في 2023
ما ينفعش 8000 بني ادم يموتوا في اسبوعين
كده واللي هو اه احنا نكمل نكمل بقيه
حياتنا عادي بمنتهى بمنته الطبيعيه ده مش
[موسيقى]
طبيعي مبدئيا انا من اول من اول الاشخاص
المطبقين ليها انا طبعا عمري ما هشرب اي
شيء ليه اي علاقه بهذا الكيان عمري ما
هاكل اي شيء ليه علاقه بهذا الكيان ليه
لان انا في الاول وفي الاخر فلوسي بنت
الامبراطوريه ديت انت شربت كام واحده من
عنده كلت كام واحده من عنده طيب فلوسك
دلوقتي بيتعمل بيها ايه فلوسك بتتبعت عشان
تشارك في حرب غير عادله
[تصفيق]
جدا بس اللي حصل دوت حصل قبل كده بس ما
ينفعش يحصل في 223 وكل حد معه تليفون في
دول كامله اتبنت بالشكل اللي اسرائيل
بتحاول تبني نفسها بيه بس ده مش هيحصل في
2023 ومش هيحصل على حسابنا ومش هيحصل على
حساب الفلسطينيين ومش هيحصل والعالم كله
بيتفرج مش هقول لك العرب كل البني ادمين
اللي عندهم ذاره انسانيه عارفين ان اللي
بيحصل دوت ما هو الا فعل شيطاني ولا يمت
لليهوديه
[موسيقى]
بالصله المظاهره ديت معموله
عشان اليهود اللي عايشين في نيويورك
طالعين يقولوا ان المجزره اللي بتحصل ديت
مش عايزين مش عايزين الموضوع يبقى باسمهم
من الاخر يعني انا انا مبسوط ان انا في
الجزء ده من العالم وشايف الكلام دوت
بيحصل قدامي اتمنى الناس
تفوت
[موسيقى]
وشك اقول اخ وما اقولش اغرب وعدين اطخطخ
ونشان
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
سو الفلسطيني لا يمتلك غير ارضه
والفلسطيني لازم المفروض يفضل واقف فوق
ارضه
[موسيقى]
ه